So I'm heading over to a fellow military wife's house right now.
Her husband is also deployed for an extremely long period of time.
Her son has really bad eczema and it's been flaring up since dad left.
So I'm heading over to drop some of this off,
so hopefully this helps.
She's tried lots of different conventional methods,
so it's time time to try some tallow
and I'll let you guys know how it goes.
Talal is a wonderful natural way to moisturize your skin.
It contains natural occurring vitamins
and minerals that help heal your skin,
which makes it perfect to treat eczema.
This one! It also includes olive oil and vanilla oil,
so it smells absolutely amazing after a few days.
My friend did report back that her son's skin side a hill
and that just makes me so happy.